what's chris rock's reaction after will
said this i've reached out to
chris and the mesh the message that came
back is that
he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out a source tells e.t chris has
no plans to reach out to will even
though will would love nothing more than
for chris to publicly accept his apology
but it's not going to happen right now
chris i apologize
to you my behavior
was
unacceptable and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk will
dropped that apology on friday four
months after the slap heard round the
world just hours later chris took the
stage for a stand-up show in atlanta
where he reportedly told the crowd if
everybody claims to be a victim then
nobody will hear the real victims even
me getting smacked by sug smith
comparing will to currently imprisoned
death row records ceo suge knight chris
added anyone who says words hurt has
never been punched in the face i am
deeply remorseful
and i'm trying to be remorseful without
being ashamed of myself our source
believes the timing of will's apology is
more about his best interest telling e.t
he needs the public's forgiveness not
chris i know
it was confusing i know it was
shocking if you if you hang on i promise
we'll be able to be friends again